all right let's hear from a few more
people via discord at davidpakman.com
discord going next to nick from brooklyn
my old
stomping ground nick from brooklyn what
uh what neighborhood are you in
oh hey i'm in bensonhurst bensonhurst
i spent uh i spent uh a week there one
night if you know what i mean
i you know that could that guy could
interpret that in several ways though
you know i'm taking the best what's
what's going on man
uh i am a little curious honestly not
necessarily anything
more so just your opinion on kind of the
future of the country
and i notice a lot of people you know a
lot of people
on the republican side they see
they seem to just see the world world in
a different way in an aspect that like
when we look
when we look at things with this
election you know we seem to see things
as very obvious as like well very
obviously there isn't data to support
certain things like all these fraudulent
claims all these things you know nothing
can be substantiated
but a lot of times when i when i see or
like when i discuss like with
my parents or when i see a lot of people
on the republican side it seems that
their interpretation of the world
is like so far removed
from the reality that it's kind of
i'm kind of curious to see how the left
can bring over these people that
see the world so differently yeah if
it's if they aren't
even willing to accept
anything different in the first place
this is a huge issue and
obviously right there's a this is a
particularly
acute problem right now because of
trumpism and
all sorts of wild claims nothing is ever
too crazy for the trumpest to defend but
this is also just a bigger issue in
america you know the country is so big
i spent some time for example in rural
northern indiana a couple of years ago
and spending time there made me
understand like
of course they voted for trump all there
is is evangelical churches so your your
entire
socializing is happening in evangelical
churches where abortion is this major
issue
one of the few things there is to do is
to shoot guns
so it's like of course they're gonna
vote for somebody like joe biden whether
or not
they think joe biden's a socialist like
if that's your environment
for your first 18 years obviously you're
voting for a republican when you turn 18
whether or not they can credibly claim
to be pro-life or not
i don't know what to do about that this
is just a bigger issue period
and it you know we have to think about
the deprogramming of of tens of millions
of people from cult-like beliefs
about it yeah i i feel like you know as
many as many
issues and and and policies we can put
forth
you know you know try to better the
world around us because it's it's one
thing when it's just like you know
we we have like the two parties to have
like or we have several but you know
generally bipartisan to
you know for people to express different
beliefs and thoughts but it seems more
so it's not just an
expression of different thought it seems
like some
are you know a lot more
i'm trying to think of what what the
term would be well there's
these are cultural issues more than they
are policy
yeah exactly so i'm just kind of curious
not necessarily that you'd have a a
complete answer to it but what do you
think would be a good way we can at
least attempt to move the culture
i mean like one thing would be if we
could on average get everybody one
additional year of education
it would actually make an electoral
difference and what i mean by that is
you take all the people who who dropped
out of school after middle school
to at least go one year to high school
everybody who never went to college take
a year of cl like if if you just
upped the average education by a year
which is a lot like that's a crit when
you have a country of 330 million
to increase the average schooling by one
year is cr it's a crazy uh
undertaking that alone i think because
of we
knowing the relationship between
education and how people vote
that would be huge in and of itself so i
do think education is a big part of it
but there are cultural aspects to it
that that are huge
it's a it's a big topic i wish i had the
answers yeah
no i i'm not expecting you to i just i
i'm just very
curious to see what your perspective
would be and like how maybe a cultural
shift
could occur in the first place just yeah
because it's still so surprising to me
like you know seeing just so much of the
country
believe in such a cult-like behavior
cultural shifts are very slow there's no
the the ways that you get fast cultural
shifts
are usually because of a dictator and so
we don't that's that we don't want that
we have to accept that it's going to be
a longer process yeah
fair enough and and final thing do you
also feel that because
of trump coming into the country that
it's
me because i feel like yes cultural
shifts do happen slowly
but this has been or maybe these are
just all people been in hiding or
[Music]
exactly i don't think trump created
these people i think he gave them a
place to
to go public and coalesce i think it's
it's it's that listen my friend i
appreciate the call i want to get
to a couple of other people but let's
hope to speak again
absolutely absolutely very good all
right excellent i want to let you know
that our sponsor vincero watches is
having a massive holiday sale on all of
their products right now
and you can take advantage of it by
going to davidpakman.com
watch a brand new high quality
wristwatch
really is the perfect way to add
something
fresh to your style whether it's for you
or a gift for someone
else vincero is a brand that has a
serious dedication to the craft of
watchmaking which is really evident when
you look closely at their watches
i wear vincero watches myself lately
i've been wearing one from their icon
automatic collection it's the mesh matte
black watch and i love the sleek
minimalist design
their watches are actually sold at a
fair price their mission has always been
to make a wrist watch
from high-end materials but one that
everyday people can afford
and that's why they have over twenty
five thousand
five star reviews because you won't find
a better made watch
for this great of a price anywhere else
you can get big holiday discounts on all
of their products right now
and free shipping when you go to
davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video